este vídeo es especial vamos a hablar de
un tema que afecta a visual polític y en
general a todo youtube no es que vayan a
hacer este canal ni muchísimo menos pero
es posible que los que nos veis desde la
unión europea no podáis volver a ver
muchos de nuestros vídeos exacto hoy
vamos a hablar del artículo 13
vamos a dejar las cosas claras desde el
primer momento aquí no somos meros
espectadores que vemos lo que pasa en el
mundo y os lo contamos para nada somos
parte activa de todo este proceso es más
los que me seguís por twitter ya sabéis
que yo he estado en bruselas hablando
sobre el artículo 13 con los políticos
que lo están negociando
[Música]
habéis oído bien a día de hoy no existe
ninguna asociación que represente a los
youtubers así que hemos ido por nuestra
cuenta un grupo de creadores europeos y
que queríamos conseguir
[Aplausos]
pues muy fácil contarles a los políticos
de bruselas todos los problemas que
tendríamos si se aprueba este artículo
para quien no lo sepa hablamos de una
directiva europea para regular el
copyright en internet y ya sé lo que os
estáis preguntando qué es exactamente el
artículo 13 de verdad es tan
catastrófico como nos lo pintan y lo que
es más importante que podemos hacer los
youtubers al respecto hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes tengo que hacer un aviso
para ti sí para ti que tienes un canal
de youtube o esperas dedicarte al mundo
del contenido online quédate hasta el
final porque vamos a dar una serie de
claves muy importantes y ahora sí vamos
a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la pregunta que más veces me han hecho
en los últimos tres años de mi vida es
se puede vivir de youtube y la respuesta
es que si para que os hagáis una idea si
sumamos visual política en inglés y
visual política en español tenemos unas
10 millones de visitas mensuales
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar eso se traduce
en algo y lo sé es un tema del que nadie
quiere hablar nunca pero hoy tenemos que
hablar de nuestro trabajo y por si
alguno se lo estaba planteando no en
visual político no ganamos como para ser
millonarios ni muchísimo menos pero sí
lo suficiente para que junto a las
donaciones de patrián podamos sacar un
ingreso digno que nos permita sacar este
proyecto adelante y sabéis que no somos
los únicos solo en españa hay más de
1000 canales de youtube que generan
suficiente audiencia como para que sus
autores tengan algo así como un salario
y puedan dedicarse a crear contenido y
en algunos casos incluso a contratar a
gente
[Música]
y algo parecido ocurre en otras
plataformas como instagram facebook o
tweets es decir que los creadores de
contenido online somos ya una industria
una industria pequeña sí pero una
industria que tiene más de 1000
trabajadores en españa y que genera
valor para toda la sociedad
es cierto youtube es una empresa de eeuu
pero el youtuber con más suscriptores
del mundo es gripal que es sueco y el
youtuber con más audiencia de todo el
mundo hispanoparlante es español vamos
que en europa no faltan creadores
[Música]
pero cuál es el problema pues el
problema es que no hay ninguna
asociación que nos represente los
grandes medios de comunicación o las
discográficas tienen sus patronales y
sus sindicatos nosotros no porque pues
porque hemos empezado muy poco a poco la
historia de cualquier canal de youtube
es la siguiente empiezas con tus propios
recursos subes vídeos porque te gusta y
a medida que vas creciendo llega un
momento donde dices oye pues mira ya
puedo dedicarme a esto al cien por cien
como os podéis imaginar a nadie se le
pasa por la cabeza montar una asociación
que nos defienda por si algún día a
europa le da por sacar una regulación de
copyright que nos afecta y os
preguntaréis cómo funciona la
legislación de copyright ahora mismo en
europa pues muy sencillo nos regimos por
la llamada directiva europea de
e-commerce que fue aprobada en el año
una directiva es una especie de
propuesta de ley que saca la unión
europea con unas líneas maestras después
cada país miembro saca su propia versión
de esa ley en el caso de españa la ley
que recoge esta directiva es la ley de
servicios de la sociedad de la
información y cómo funciona esta ley
pues bien vamos a imaginar que yo subo a
visual político un videoclip de un grupo
de música por ejemplo de tasmania que
bueno ya sabéis que son buenos amigos de
visual política pero vamos a imaginar
que subo una canción suya sin su permiso
es decir estoy haciendo algo ilegal
en ese momento tasmania o la
discográfica que tenga sus derechos me
puede denunciar pero me denuncia a mí y
me puede exigir que pague una multa
millonaria a mí cuál es el problema pues
como os podéis imaginar el problema es
el dinero
yo no puedo pagar una multa millonaria
porque simplemente no tengo un millón de
euros entonces qué pueden hacer tasmania
pues se van a youtube y le piden que
quite el vídeo para estas cosas youtube
tiene un filtro especial que se llama
content ayby en este caso envían su
canción a youtube youtube es caminar la
canción busca todos los vídeos donde
aparece y los bloquea esto qué es lo que
dice la ley
[Música]
pero ahora viene la parte interesante
porque en este momento llegan tasmania y
le dicen a youtube que a tu momento
youtube y si en lugar de quitar las
canciones nos pagas una licencia hasta
ahora la ley no dice nada sobre eso es
decir youtube está obligado a quitar la
canción si se lo piden pero la ley no
dice nada sobre negociar contratos sin
embargo como la gente de youtube es muy
estupenda les dice no os preocupéis
vamos a hacer negocios si os parece os
voy a pagar un porcentaje del dinero que
generemos con los anuncios que van en
ese vídeo es decir que negocian un
contrato y diréis es un porcentaje alto
o un porcentaje bajo pues según las
discográficas es bastante bajo fijaos en
lo que decía paul mccartney el de los
beatles en este artículo
hoy algunas plataformas de contenido
generado por usuarios no quieren
compensar justamente a los artistas y a
los creadores por su trabajo mientras
que lo explotan para su propio beneficio
ser paul mccartney y os preguntaréis
pero vale tiene razón paul mccartney o
no pues lo cierto es que no lo sabemos
según youtube las discográficas reciben
la mayor parte del dinero de la
publicidad pero por otro lado esas
mismas discográficas mantienen una
política de estricta confidencialidad en
sus contratos y por si alguno se lo
estaba preguntando si obviamente he
hablado con dos asociaciones del sector
y ninguna me ha querido decir nada solo
sabemos una cosa asociación es como un
tipo impala que son las que representan
a las discográficas en bruselas quieren
que youtube les pague más y para eso
necesitan una posición más fuerte en las
negociaciones y eso cómo se consigue
pues con una nueva ley de copyright y
así es como en el año 2016 la comisión
europea que es algo así como el gobierno
de europa
sacó el
borrador de las llamadas
directiva para el copyright en el
mercado único europeo
[Aplausos]
según esta ley youtube y todas las demás
plataformas de contenidos están
obligadas a compensar a los dueños del
copyright es decir que los de youtube ya
no compensan a las discográficas porque
sean generosos porque son estupendos
ahora lo hacen porque la ley les obliga
y eso se traduce en una negociación
mucho más favorable para las
discográficas en principio no suena tan
mal verdad pues esperad porque ahora
viene lo malo
el está en los detalles como
sabéis la comisión europea no puede
aprobar directivas se las tienen que
proponer al parlamento y al consejo
europeo y son estas dos instituciones
las que redactan dos versiones distintas
de la directiva y aquí es donde empiezan
los problemas
[Música]
los proveedores de servicios de difusión
de contenidos realizan un acto de
comunicación hacia el público
artículo 13 párrafo 1 versión del
parlamento europeo y diréis bueno y
dónde está el problema en este artículo
bueno os voy a traducir el texto legal
básicamente esto significa que youtube
pasa a ser responsable y limitado del
contenido que se publica en la
plataforma volvamos al ejemplo de
tasmania ahora ya no sólo me denuncian a
mí por violar su copyright me denuncian
a mí y a youtube y mis queridos amigos
de visual político los de youtube sí que
tienen dinero para pagar las multas en
otras palabras que con esta ley en la
mano
youtube se tendría que gastar millones
de euros en abogados
pensadlo bien cada día se suben a
youtube más de 500.000 horas de vídeo
todos los días
esos son millones de vídeos por pura
estadística muchos de estos vídeos
tendrán alguna violación de copyright y
basta con que un solo usuario suba una
canción que no debe para que a youtube
le pueda caer una multa millonaria y que
tiene que hacer youtube para evitar todo
esto pues muy sencillo construir un muro
un muro muy estricto básicamente
cualquier vídeo que tenga contenido de
terceros estaría excluido dentro de la
unión europea por supuesto los que veáis
este vídeo desde latinoamérica o eeuu no
tendréis problemas pero si estáis en
europa mala suerte
y como sabe youtube que es contenido de
terceros y que es contenido original de
creadores pues es casi imposible
identificarlo básicamente cualquier
vídeo que no fuera una persona hablando
de una cámara tendría problemas todo
vídeo sería ilegal hasta que no se
demuestre lo contrario y eso incluye
este mismo vídeo porque ahora mismo os
voy a poner esta fantástica cita de
donald trump en la cnn
y ya sé lo que me vais a decir chicos
esto no es ilegal con la ley en la mano
tú tienes derecho a citar otras fuentes
verdad pues sí tiene razón legalmente
puedo citar a donald trump en la cnn
pero esa barrera que tendría que poner
youtube no es un abogado es un algoritmo
o una red neuronal y ese algoritmo
solamente ve contenido protegido
bloquear y lo mismo ocurre si es enseño
este trocito de mi videoclip favorito de
tasmania
[Música]
yo solo
es legal mostraros este trocito de la
canción de tasmania pues no por supuesto
que no pero los algoritmos y saben de
derecho ni saben de sentido del humor al
menos por ahora y si no que se lo
pregunten a mi amigo jaime altozano que
está todo el santo día peleándose con
estas cosas pero esperad un momento
porque hay una alternativa si hay una
solución una solución que satisface a
las discográficas satisface a youtube y
satisface a los creadores ahora mismo la
vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
qué se puede hacer al respecto como os
decía antes esta directiva de copyright
se ha votado en el parlamento europeo
pero eso no significa que se haya
terminado de aprobar en realidad solo
estamos en la mitad del camino veréis el
proceso para sacar una directiva europea
es el siguiente primero la comisión
europea la propone y ahí tenemos el
primer borrador del artículo 13 después
el parlamento redacta su texto y lo vota
y ahí tenemos el segundo borrador del
artículo 13 pero hay un tercer actor el
consejo europeo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para que os hagáis una idea el consejo
europeo sería algo así como el senado en
españa' y ellos también tienen su propia
versión del artículo 13 es decir que no
hay un único artículo 13
en realidad hay tres el de la comisión
el del parlamento y el del consejo y qué
pasa ahora pues ahora estamos en la fase
de negociación o dicho el lenguaje
brüstle y está en los diálogos imaginad
una habitación con una mesa muy grande
por un lado tenemos al representante de
la comisión europea que entra con sus
asesores por el otro a los del
parlamento y por el otro a los del
consejo todos ellos vienen con sus
asesores
entonces hablamos de unas 30 personas
que se reúnen todas las semanas para
enmendar lo que se vota en el parlamento
como os podéis imaginar se trata de un
proceso muy lento en este caso hablamos
de tres textos diferentes y creedme la
versión del artículo 13 que propone el
consejo europeo es muy distinta
[Música]
en la ausencia de una autorización un
proveedor de contenidos online no será
responsable de la comunicación al
público si demuestra que ha hecho los
mejores esfuerzos y bajo notificación
del propietario de los derechos ha
actuado de manera expeditiva para borrar
o bloquear el acceso a esos trabajos
artículo 13 párrafo 4 vale voy a
traducir esto significa que youtube es
responsable por el contenido que hay en
la plataforma sí pero tiene
responsabilidad limitada y esto qué
significa vamos a volver otra vez al
ejemplo de tasmania con esta ley youtube
estaría obligado a informarles de que
puede haber canciones en su plataforma y
les tiene que preguntar si quieren que
las bloquee o si quieren que se les
pague una licencia a partir de ahí la
discográfica de tasmania tendrá que
meter todos sus datos y metadatos en un
formulario esta forma ese filtro que
tiene youtube que se llama content haití
ya sabe lo que tiene que rastrear porque
se lo han dicho
pero no sólo eso según esta versión del
artículo 13 si youtube demuestra que ha
hecho todo lo posible para proteger el
copyright no se le puede demandar en
otras palabras que youtube ya estaría
contento porque evita todo ese riesgo
jurídico si vale tendría que pagar más a
las discográficas pero no se pasaría el
día en los juzgados por otra parte los
youtubers también estaríamos contentos
porque ya no tendríamos ese muro que se
lleva a casi todos nuestros vídeos y
finalmente esta versión también
garantiza que las discográficas puedan
negociar en igualdad de condiciones con
las plataformas online
[Música]
en resumen cuál es la diferencia entre
la posición del parlamento y la del
consejo pues que las consecuencias del
texto del parlamento son que youtube se
convertiría en en un canal de televisión
más solo los grandes creadores podrían
sobrevivir porque pues porque son los
únicos que pueden pagarse un abogado que
les gestione su copyright para que
youtube les deje subir vídeos pero
existiría un muro imposible de cruzar
para cientos de miles de pequeños
creadores sin embargo existe una forma
de hacer un acuerdo justo para todas las
partes y en esencia de eso es de lo que
trata la política y os preguntaréis que
vendría después pues después de que se
negoció esta directiva en los diálogos
se vuelve a llevar al parlamento ahí
tiene que ser votada a favor o en contra
cuando se votaría pues no lo sabemos
porque depende de lo que tarden en
negociar
[Música]
lo cierto es que una vez que se hubiera
ratificado en el parlamento habría que
llevarla a los parlamentos nacionales es
decir cada país miembro de la unión
europea tendría que sacar su propia ley
siguiendo las guías de esta directiva y
ahí es donde volvemos a entrar los
creadores online y si os estoy hablando
a vosotros los que tenéis un canal sí
incluido tú está la review que seguro
que me estás viendo la próxima semana
vamos a hacer un directo aquí en visual
político ahí vamos a responder a todas
las preguntas que tengáis sobre el
artículo 13 he hablado con todas las
partes incluidas las discográficas
youtube el consejo europeo la comisión
europea y el parlamento y si algo he
aprendido estando una semana entera en
bruselas es que hay un montón de
estereotipos con respecto a lo que es un
creador online de entrada nadie nos ve
como lo que somos un sector económico
con muchas pequeñas empresas y como
nadie sabe que hay miles de personas que
trabajamos y que vivimos de esto nadie
se imagina la cantidad de gente que
sería el paro si se aprueba una mala
regulación así que
la fecha 5 de diciembre a las 7 de la
tarde hora española os espero a todos en
directo donde pues lógicamente aquí en
visual político y como siempre si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like
suscribiros al canal darle a la
campanita para que os lleguen todas las
actualizaciones y bueno pues compartirlo
con vuestros amigos un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Aplausos]
[Música]